hola qué tal mi nombre es soma rueda
tengo 36 años aunque parezco de 35 con
11 meses y 25 días originario de este
puerto de coatzacoalcos veracruz quiero
agradecer
los organizadores de este primer tedesco
acuáticos por la invitación a todos
ustedes por estar aquí presentes
este evento tiene un eslogan con el cual
yo me sentí identificado desde la
primera vez que lo escuché ese eslogan
es renacimiento porque hace un año con
siete meses
me tocó vivir en carne propia el
significado del renacer les platico
porque el 4 de junio del 2018 a las 16
horas aproximadamente
me topé cara a cara con mil 79
kilómetros por hora que cambiaron mi
vida completamente ustedes se
preguntarán por qué es porque a esa
velocidad viaja una bala calibre 22
desde ese momento mi vida cambió
rotundamente
y víctima de un asalto después de haber
realizado una operación de dinero en
efectivo en una sucursal bancaria
con ello pasé a ser parte de las
estadísticas delictivas de la ciudad
ese día que en realidad no existe en mi
memoria y que lo que aquí les platico es
gracias a la recopilación de datos de
amigos y familiares
ya que yo ni siquiera vi venir a los
asaltantes cuando venían hacia mí
imaginen por un momento que me
encontraba estacionando la unidad en la
cual me transportaba para posteriormente
ingresar a mi centro de trabajo cuando
de repente de mi lado izquierdo aparece
un tipo saca un arma de fuego y me
dispara a quemarropa quedando bañado en
un charco de sangre y sin conciencia
desde ese momento les repito mi vida
cambia rotundamente
quiero hacer énfasis
la importancia que es la amistad en este
tipo de situaciones
esto se los digo porque gracias a que
compañeros de trabajo más que pensar
actuaron para poderme bajar de la unidad
ponerme en el suelo
y con ello
poder tapar con un trapo la herida y
evitar que yo pudiera desangrar nos
siguiera desangrando me en lo que
llegaba los cuerpos de emergencia
auxiliar me
imaginen que si ellos no hubieran
actuado yo no estaría aquí frente a
ustedes platicando
esa acción que marca diferencia en
cuestión de segundos en cuestión de
minutos
finalmente desde las 4 de la tarde que
les platico que sucedió esto
fue hasta las 12 de la noche
yo fui atendido esto gracias a que en
medio del caos y la incertidumbre a
alguien se le ocurrió
me trasladaron a una clínica particular
hasta las 12 de la noche
un médico un cirujano un neurólogo con
todas las expectativas en mi contra y
gracias a sus conocimientos a sus manos
esa operación fue un éxito después de
eso los siguientes minutos las
siguientes horas
eran vitales para mi recuperación que se
dio en menos tiempo del que habían
estipulado cuando finalmente yo puedo
reaccionar
lo primero que veo es una enfermedad al
pie de mi cama
lo primero que escuché es que me dijo
estate tranquilo vas a estar bien y al
mismo tiempo yo veía que estaba bañado
en mi cuerpo todavía con manchas de
sangre y con ello tubos sondas por
mencionarle algunas cosas
cuando finalmente logró despertar
yo no sabía qué situación me habían
vuelto o me había mandado ahí
posteriormente a eso puedo regresar a mi
casa después de 15 días una vez
recuperado el conocimiento y que la
evolución era lenta pero favorable
una vez estando en mi domicilio
me percato de que en mi habitación me
acompaña mi cama de siempre
siguió un tipo reposet y un barandal y
en ese preciso momento
en mi se interna una voz que me dijo
omar ya valiste ya no podrás caminar
es hasta el siguiente día cuando yo me
entero en realidad que me había sucedido
y la verdad al enterarme yo no daba
crédito no podía creer como una persona
le puede cambiar la vida a otra en
cuestión de segundos
imaginen ustedes que inmediatamente
cuando yo pienso en eso o me dicen eso
el balazo pasó a segundo término
inmediatamente él quien había sido o
quienes lo habían mandado a hacer ya no
importaba lo que en mi mente estaba era
ese momento de negatividad de ya no
podrás caminar mucho menos correr mucho
menos ir al fútbol mucho menos ir a
cantar con la orquesta mucho menos ir al
béisbol y bailar porque soy honesto me
encanta la pachanga
en ese momento mi vida comenzó a estar
recibiendo una serie de negatividad es
internas cuando yo regreso con el
cirujano que me opera para retirarme los
puntos en la operación de la cabeza
y un chequeo en general me dice vas muy
bien
y otra vez esa voz interna de cual bien
si sigo estando atado a una silla de
ruedas sin poder moverme y en todo
momento ser asistido por alguien
la verdad que es una situación muy
difícil pero al mismo tiempo el doctor
le comenta a mi hermana que me
acompañaba en esa cita que yo tenía que
empezar a recibir terapia física para
empezar a recuperar mis movimientos
una vez que analizado con una
fisioterapeuta de la ciudad al revisar
me empieza a mover mis piernas mis manos
y la verdad me tronaba todo era
inevitable llorar sentía dolor y esa voz
de la doctora te vas a recuperar rápido
hijo tuve nueve meses a más tardar un
año estarás caminando por ti mismo y
otra vez la voz interna a su no pues que
rápido no
una vez que empiezo mis terapias físicas
este chip empieza a ese chip interior
empieza a cambiar el conocer tanta gente
niños jóvenes adultos como le echaban
ganas a diferentes situaciones que
tenían para volver a recuperar sus
movimientos fue en ese preciso momento
cuando yo logré ver a un señor de la
tercera edad 85 años pónganle pedaleando
una bicicleta tras sufrir tres infartos
en ese preciso momento ese chip interior
mío cambio el no podrás él no lo vas a
lograr cambio por él con esfuerzo se
logran cosas importantes si salve la
vida tengo que hacer que valga la pena
que continuó estando aquí
lo que ya pasó queda atrás y a partir de
ahora es lo que tú tienes que hacer
en realidad ha sido una etapa muy muy
difícil y parte de ellos se los quiero
presentar
en el siguiente vídeo
[Música]
[Aplausos]
es
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
créanme
hay desgracias que dejan enseñanzas
importantes yo en esta etapa muy difícil
por cierto para mí para mi familia
aprendí que si la vida te da una segunda
oportunidad hay que aprovecharla al
máximo porque muchos ya no la tienen que
si la vida te pone pruebas difíciles
tienes que superarte que la vida es muy
difícil por donde la queramos ver
que en momentos difíciles cuenta mucho
el apoyo de tu familia de tus amigos la
ayuda divina por supuesto pero quien
importa es uno mismo y si uno no quiere
hacer las cosas no las vas a lograr hay
una frase muy cierta que dice la vida a
veces te tira pero solamente de ti
depende si quieres levantarte en este
proceso muy difícil
la única discapacidad que yo desarrolle
es la hipoacusia que significa sordera
el impacto me quebré unos huesos que
conectan con el tímpano y perdí la
audición del lado izquierdo al 100% pero
como pueden ver no me impide ni me
limita de muchas cosas estoy empezando a
retomar mi vida normal puedo seguir
saliendo a la calle saludando amigos
puede ir al béisbol regrese al fútbol
regresé a cantar con la orquesta
y también ya puedo ir a las fiestas que
también es importante
cuando estuve a punto pues de ya no
hacerlo estuve a punto de dejar de
existir ya no vivir en mi vida
y con todo eso en contra estoy aquí de
pie
what's a cual cause y todo el país
entero no es para vivir con miedo cada
rincón de nuestro país de nuestra ciudad
es para disfrutar es para vivir con
precaución
soy una rueda están en texas cualquier
cual muchas gracias
[Aplausos]